in real life we don't want anybody to
know how we feel most of the time
if somebody makes us angry
we don't want to show it
what is acting thanks for that question
because a lot of people think that
acting is lying
and that's you know one of those things
that I think is the most important thing
about it is that it's my my teacher my
my teacher my
special teacher Gene Shelton who just
passed away recently
used to say that
people think that acting is lying but
really acting is being more truthful
than you get to be in real life
and that was always the that was always
the joy of it for me I always felt like
a little bit of a fraud in real life and
I always felt like characters were
saying and doing things that I was
didn't dare to do that they were that
they were a deeper part of me
so
that's what I love about acting is that
it's more truthful than real life it's
not lying at all
um and and a very common definition is
acting as living truthfully under
imaginary circumstances
that's a definition that a lot of people
use I did want to mention that
um
when I was learning acting when I was in
acting class back in the 1970s
are
God if you will was Marlon Brando
and um
and in those days you know you didn't
have access to all kinds of ways of
finding out about actors they didn't
talk about things and they were
interviewed but and Brando was of course
notoriously uh reserved and um but he
was going to be on a dick habit you know
a big interview show so everybody in our
class we all
stayed home
no be you know no way to record things
in those days we all stayed home to
watch Brando on be interviewed on the
Dick Cavett Show and
um
he said he said well acting everybody is
nothing it's uh it's just everybody acts
all the time because people never tell
you what they really think so everybody
is acting all the time and we're so
disappointed to hear him say that
because we've we felt so you know
involved in our craft and so uh deeply
deeply connected to the truthfulness and
the of of acting and and finding the
truth of the character the truth of the
play or film and um
but what I come to think is that what he
was saying what he really meant is that
whatever people say there is subtext to
it
okay and that I do think is exactly
right that in real life as well as for
characters in a movie or television show
or play there's always subtext to what
people are saying so in real life people
will ask you how you are and you will
say I'm fine and that will be very often
a lie right but there's if you let
yourself believe that there's always
subject so for example if you ask me how
are you and I might say well I'm shitty
but uh this is my subtex threat this is
what I'm not saying I feel really shitty
but I'm going to give you a break and
not tell you all about it instead I'm
going to say I'm fine
okay so even when that seems like a lie
somebody says how are you and I say I'm
fine it seems like a lie but really
there's always subtext and
um and that's true for acting there's
always subtext so in that sense I've
come around to understanding that that
that Brando's uh definition of acting is
also completely valid
why do you say that acting is more
honest than real life
because real life is so Bound by the
social parameters by what's socially
acceptable
and characters go way outside of what's
socially acceptable they go into places
of deep pain they go into places of
transgression they go into places of uh
of joy and and uh
exuberance that isn't really socially
acceptable
um
and and in fact
let me put this another way a lot of
feeling is not socially acceptable
when people
in in real life we don't want anybody to
know how we feel most of the time
if somebody makes us angry
we don't want to show it
and we even say to each other don't let
that person get to you
don't let him know that he bothers you
right and that's a real watch for it for
getting along in the social world is to
not let people know when they when
they've upset you to not let them know
if they've hurt your feelings to not let
them know if they've made you angry to
not and very often
to not let them know if uh if they've
turned you on if they've you know made
you feel excited in their presence
so
and actors get to do that they they get
to they get to express things that are
very human things that
um
that in real life are are frowned upon
you know the social parameters are very
strict
often
so the notion that acting is lying where
do you think that came from
from people who don't know anything
about acting well I think if you don't
know anything about how what acting is
about is really about the subtext
then it's easy to think that it's it
it's not that people are stupid for
thinking that because an actor is
pretending to be in love with somebody
when they're married to somebody else or
they're you know they're they're
pretending to uh murder somebody
uh when they're when they claim that
they're an upstanding citizen so
um
I could see where where it comes from
that it you know that it has to do with
uh that people would think that
but it's unfortunate
um it it has to do with not
understanding this idea of subtext that
that an actor can be completely truthful
with their own subtext and an actor
never needs to let go of their own
values or their own uh yeah their own
values their own ethics
an actor never needs to let go of those
and and I don't know I like to keep
telling people about that that that uh
you know an actor can be capable of
approaching every character without
judgment very important for an actor not
to judge their character to to be on
their character's side to look for the
ways that the character is
doing what they think is best is doing
the best they can
but without and to understand that as a
craft
and it doesn't mean that you have to let
go of your own ethics sure but you could
say that we all have certain parts of
every character in us whether we act
exactly exactly we all have impulses we
all have we all have every impulse every
single person has every single impulse
in them somewhere now for some people
they're buried so far down that they
won't wouldn't recognize it in
themselves for actors they allow those
things to be buried less far down you
know so that they can access them but it
doesn't mean that they change their
beliefs about what's right and wrong